so hopefully by the end of the day
you'll have a pretty good idea about how
you might undertake one of these surveys
so it's kind of going to be very
practical hands-on about how you might
undertake these you will probably if you
are to do one look up the references and
get more detail than but hopefully it'll
give you enough to get you going
evaluation so the first one is travel
cost so travel cost is a revealed
preference technique and so what you're
doing is trying to work out the value of
usually a recreation site and it's
revealed by observing actual behavior so
one of the nice things about travel cost
method is its base and that people's
actual real behavior so people are
traveling to the Grand Canyon they're
traveling to yield forest whatever
natural resource that you're looking at
so in Nice thing compared to this
compared to the state of preference
techniques it's real behavior state of
preference techniques we ask people
hypothetical questions about how they
value it which can be an issue so what
the background to travel cost is that
we're assuming that if you traveled at
Grand Canyon than that time and money
you spend traveling to that resource say
something about how much you value that
resort so that's a basic premise of the
travel cost method unfortunately it's
not quite as simplistic as that so the
origins it came back to 1947 when a guy
called Heidel hoteling he was a national
park warden and his boss asked him what
why should I give you more money for
investing in his naturalist Park and he
had to find justify it so wrote a letter
to his boss and say well people are
traveling all around America all around
the world to come to this site I can't
remember who it's like it was but if
they were willing to spend that money
coming here surely that has something to
do with demonstrating that it must be
important to them and so the kind of
basic concept came from late 1940s and a
few P
did a couple studies but there's no real
theoretical foundations to it and it
wasn't - until 1966 with Jack Lawson and
Mariana - that they put some economic
theory underlying it so it's only 1966
it really took hold with some good sound
economic theory and since then it has
developed maybe in recent years it
hasn't been used quite as much when some
of the more stated preference techniques
of state preference but it's still a
very very useful technique for valuing
sites where people travel - so it
shouldn't be too miss dismissed and the
way the methods developed that and it
can tell us a lot more than some of the
original versions so what can we use to
travel costs to measure current access
to actually recreation sites so if
you've got Grand Canyon we can measure
the consumer surplus value that of
visitors to the Grand Canyon
so what are current people going to that
site so how far we travel in the Hat and
how much benefit getting it may also
look at elimination of our site so if
you've got say a wetland area and then
there's some industrial development and
they want to kind of build on this
wetland area then we can do a travel
cost site see how important it is and
then based on that we can try and
measure how important or to evaluation
so if if wetland site disappears we can
see something about how important it is
some more sophisticated ones called the
random parameters or sorry random
utility travel cost method what that
does is allow you to value different for
sites and look at the value different
attributes of that site so if you're
thinking about creating a new Forest
Park you can maybe take information from
the other sites and the fair the value
of a new park so that's kind of more
kind of sophisticated use of a travel
cost method and similar with the random
utility want model we can look at
different elements environmental quality
so how does a park it's got more
broadleaf trees compared to one with
conifers and again I'll describe
utility one later on so there's a whole
kind of series of different ways that we
can value our recreation resource what
is important to remember from last day
if you remember we introduced the
concept of total economic value and that
comprised per views and non use values
while the travel cost method can only
look at the use values so it's only
looking at people actively using that
site it doesn't say anything about
people's future use of that resource or
anything else so it's just the use
values and that's maybe one of the
limitations when there's been a lot of
interest in looking at the non use
values of environmental resources so if
we look at the travel cost method there
are three basic models that have been
used and generally the zonal model was
the first one really introduced and the
individual in random utility modules or
more sophisticated ones and therefore
and the zonal model has a lot of basic
assumptions and to a large extent most
of assumptions assumptions are violated
so the individual and ranty utility
model relax some of the assumptions so
it collects more data and becomes better
models so one quantity over the next ten
minutes or so is go through how we might
do a Sunol travel cost model and that's
the easiest way of getting the concept
across and then I'll introduce a
individual and run to be tilty models
and show how the assumptions and how
they improve the way we do travel cost
methods so the zonal model was the
original application of travel cost and
you can actually run a zone the travel
cost model with secondary data so if
your national park has data on visitors
where they come from you can just use
that so you don't necessarily need so
every work but most often we do collect
a little bit survey data but doesn't
have be too detailed generally what you
can only value with the zonal cost is a
total value of a recreation resource so
what's the total value of that site you
can't say anything about the different
quality or that site and so forth
so if the basic premise is you can see
we've got this say forest park here at
some point and what we wanted to do is
look at people traveling to that site so
a simple method is we just create a
number of zones away from that site and
what you're going to then do is look at
how much of course from people and so on
to travel the site how much people are
so into traveling to that site and how
much people swim through and outside
that zone so it could be very simply
just abuse concentric zoo in circles so
from nought to ten miles ten to 20 miles
20 to 30 miles or if it's Grand Canyon
you might do nought to 100 miles 100 to
200 miles so the spacing between us
Owens will depend largely on how
important the site how far people will
travel through that site or you may do
Geographic divisions so look at tease
around that site and the benefit of
doing that is if you've got County
information you've got easy way of
working out how many people live in that
site and therefore what proportion of
people from that zone the route travels
to it then what you do is you collect or
you go to the site and you say okay
where have you traveled from so we
collect information about the number of
people traveling to the site from each
of those zones then the next stage is
you need to try and work out what
proportion of people from each zone is
traveling to that recreation site so out
of each thousand people in that
population how many people are traveling
and what you can imagine is if you're
closer to a site a higher proportion
will go there so if it's a ye'll forest
then people the nail will go there it's
it's close there are fewer substitutes
of similar type of sites close buys or
maybe 10% of a population of Yale will
go to Yale
Forest wherever you go further away to
New York then maybe only 1% of people
living in New York might come up here
you move further away fewer people or
fewer proportion of people go to that
site and part of that reason is there's
more substitute site so if you live in
New York I'll be forest there so why
travel all the way to Yale where you can
simply go to the forest outside New York
so here's some hypothetical data we've
got so we've got a three zone so we're
seeing these zone 0 is people pretty
much living in the forest and so in 1 2
3 and Beyond and just for simplicity
we're assuming that we get 400 people
visiting so overall we've got six
hundred sixteen hundred visitors of
which 400 are living inside a hundred
are and so on and so forth
and a number of people in the zone
partly because if you've got 10 mile
radius eat so in this area gets bigger
so again I'm just simply assuming that's
a thousand people live in zone 0 2,000
people live in zone 1 and so forth 8,000
and so and 3 and you can get this data
pretty safe from census data and then
what we've went to trying to is work I
visits per thousand so here that's 400
people visiting inside at a population
of a thousand so there's 400 visits per
thousand here's 400 people like
population of 2000 so as 200 visitors
per thousand and so forth and here are
50 people per thousand so we can say the
proportion of people traveling through
that site gets less and less as you go
further away from that site and that's
what you'd expect
so what we'll be doing is taking this
information here I use it to create a
chip trip generation function so I'll
describe that and a couple slice time ok
so then the next thing we need to do is
calculate how much it's costing people
within each zone to travel to the site
and with a basic zonal system what we're
doing is just getting an average cost
for everybody in that site so when we're
thinking about the cost of traveling
it's not only the cost in terms I'll say
your fuel to
going to the side but also your time so
you're spending some time they travel to
the psyche and we win want to try
incorporate some element all that time
so if you've got people and so on zero
if you live in the side and this model
we're assuming the zero travel distance
and time so receiving if you live in the
forest so it's they're not going to
spend any money or time getting there
it's already there and then for the
people in the other zones on one and
three and Beyond then I basically just
meet some very basic assumptions so in
this example we're assuming that costs
of travel is 30 pence per mile so for
each mile from a zoo and it's going to
cost you 30 pence and we're going to
assume that and that you've got an
average hourly weight of time rate of
time cost of time with nine pound or
that rates to 15 pence per minute so
it's in pounds and so forth not dollars
but again it's very basic assumptions
about how much it costs people in terms
of time and we can add those two
together so it's a table kind of
demonstrating how we might do it so so
in 0 another time no distance the time
so it's not going to cost the man thing
so in 1 we're assuming here that the
average distance and soon one is 20
miles to a mileage of 20 miles and if it
costs 3 pounds per mile that's going to
be six pounds in travel costs and if
they're traveling for 30 minutes and
it's 15 pence per minute that's going to
be 4 pounds 50 so we're assuming that
people in zone 1 it's going to cost them
10 pound 50 to travel to that site and
again it's very basic assumption with
the sonim 1 we're just assuming
everybody in suin one will spend 10
pounds 50 pounds traveling to that site
and we'll come back and discuss some of
these assumptions and we do similar
things here so here's 40 miles here at
80 miles and we can apply these rates to
get different costs so from different
zones of other way you are it's going to
cost you more so it's nothing new about
that so what we then want to do is this
information here doesn't really tell us
anything about
how much people value it all it says
that people value it at least that
amount so what we need to do is generate
what's called the trip generation
function and what that is is looking at
the proportion of people traveling to a
site relative to the travel costs so
what we do is use a data from the first
table on the proportion of people
traveling per thousand population and
the data from the last table to do a
regression to generate a trip generation
function so what we do is do a
regression so visits per thousand from
the first table I'm regressing against
travel costs one is just the intersect
and so that's a very basic model you
might want to include social economics
deacon in there but for a simple example
all we're doing is regressing the
proportion of people traveling to that
site relative to the travel costs and
here's the results of regression so the
coefficient and travel cost is minus
seven point seven five so it's negative
so as travel costs increase fewer people
will go to that site so so that seems
fine
so what we then do we've got this trip
generation function here and then what
we use that for is to try and work out
how people might behave in terms of
increasing costs of travel to the site
so if we increase the travel costs by
say a hypothetical entry fee
how would that reduce the number of
people traveling to that site we're
using a trip generation function to do
that and that information we can
generate the man curve so what we've got
is different hypothetical entry fees so
what would happen in terms of number of
visits if we had entry fee of ten pounds
or ten dollars what would happen if we
had twenty dollars and so forth and how
would that affect total number of visits
so the first and that created the man
curve and you remember from last day the
consumer surplus is the area under
demand curve so we can generate this
demand curve and work out this area of
the value over number two
people we can work out the overall value
of that site so this generate demand
curve the first point is the current
situation so if for currently there's no
hypothetical entry for you it's just the
travel cost so currently I know extra
cost
there's going to be sixteen hundred
people so that sixteen hundred came from
a very first table of a number of people
going there so these are people
traveling from zones one to zones three
so that's the first point and then the
real crux of how we work out the other
points is through the trip generation
function so what we're going to assume
now is if we charge this hypothetical
entry fee of ten pounds so in addition
to a travel costs how will people
respond in terms of number of visits if
we have an extra ten pounds to that
travel I'm sorry so every people think
about people in zone zero so this is our
generation function here so 33 or 330
minus 7 point 7 5 x travel costs and so
so in 0 there's no the travel cost is a
ten-pound here for a type of entry so
we're adding an extra 10 pounds and
that'll give us 249 people trips so by
working through the trip generation
function and saying if a travel cost is
10 pounds we will get third 249 trips
for zone 0 so that's that first bit in
this table then 4 so in 1 the original
travel the original travel cost was 10
pounds that's how much you're actually
spending if we add this hypothetical
temper in a mix of 20 pounds and we take
it through the trip generation function
and that gives 169 trips visits per
thousand people so what were estimates
visit their fly zone so it's 169 and
this case is 2,000 people so we'll
multiply that by 2 and that gives us a
338 and similarly for people in soon to
original travel costs we're tweeting one
pound we add on that ten pound
hypothetical entry fee so then you
total cost of travel is 31 pounds we are
that sorry we don't have that up here
but we are that in go through some
process through this trip generation
function that alone come up with 88
trips per thousand people there's 4,000
people in that zone so multiply 80 by
four we get that amount and if we do it
for some three I think an extra 10 pound
will mean that's actually negative so by
adding the extra 10 pound to people and
so in three they won't actually travel
to the site and then what we to work out
is add these up and we get 939 so if we
increase the cost of travel through his
hypothetical entry fee by 10 pounds we
would reduce the number of people go
into that site from 100 1,600 people the
vast new travel cost to 939 so that
becomes her second point in our demand
curve and then what we do is say okay
what we add 20 pound and we go through
that same process and we'll get a
reduced number of people and so forth so
if you do that with the data we've got
we get this demand curve so point one
was zero hypothetical into three point
two with ten point three to 20 and so
forth and after about 42 pounds that
nobody will travel to that site it's
going to be too costly to going there so
that gets our demand curve and if we
then work I so we can do differential
calculus to work out the area under
there and we can get the value I think
it's about a thousand pounds or
something in this case so you can you
can work it out yourself so that's kind
of very basic zonal travel cost how you
do it so you're not actually using the
cost of travel directly to work out the
value what you're doing is you're using
a cost of travel to estimate the trip
generation function and through your
children generation function you can
work out a demand curve so how people
respond to different costs of travel and
that gives you the mind curve and we can
work out the value
so within that there's a whole bunch of
assumptions so we're assuming that the
populations in each zone is is
homogeneous so everybody in each zone
has the same travel costs we've got same
income a same social economic
backgrounds and we're also assuming that
people across the zones are similar in
terms of their social economic status
and clearly that's not quite the case
people face the same travel costs again
that might not be K so where I live in
Wales I live on the Nature Reserve and
I'm one side of the estuary and but if
you want to travel to nature to Sarah
from the other side to s3 you've got a
30 mile detour so even though it might
be just one mile away you might have a
30 mile trip compared to people on the
other side where it's a village about
mile away so people don't face the same
travel costs to get there with even
within each zone and you might have to
adjust for that travel if you the same
away as an entry fee so if you jump in
your car and travel ten miles and it
cost you five dollars do you think about
that five dollars of terms of your fuel
use the same way if someone tried to
charge you five dollars an entry fee and
again people tend to not really think
too much about because the travel but
they do think about handing over an
entry fee so there might be issues there
another big deep debate is how much you
value time so what is my opportunity
cost of time so is it my wage rate so if
I say if I worked in McDonald's so I get
$10 an hour or whatever you get so am i
giving up that time for making $10 an
hour from working McDonald's and you
could argue that case but if you're on a
salary then it's very difficult to work
out what your hourly rate is and also
would I want to give up my time or would
I actually work extra so my recreation
time is probably less in my actual work
time there's a lot of debate about what
the value of time is and I'll say it a
little bit more ly
another big issue if you could in one
site so if I fly over to America and say
good the Koran Canyon is my visit to try
and Canyon their main reason for coming
to America and it might be you might
think wow this is amazing or am I in a
business trip where so for example move
over here nice to New York I might
decide over weekend to see something New
York and it's do you lose my whole
travel cost from UK or is it just from
New Haven so there's a whole bunch of
issues about how important the site is
in terms your recreation trip and how
you deal with it and do you take it from
your whole day address or so forth so
again that's another big issue we need
to think about and in the basic zone of
travel cost method these are all kind of
big issues and them very sweeping
assumptions that we can't really rely on
and so the individual in random utility
travel cost methods have been developed
to try and relax some of those
assumptions so it kind of better account
for some of these things so if we think
of now of the individual travel cost
rather than assuming everybody needs a
zone it's homogeneous what it does is
collects actual data from each traveler
and so you work out each individual
where if they travel from you work out
their actual cost of travel so you've
got individual specific data so it's a
much more refined way of doing it it
might cost a little bit more in terms of
data collection but I think it's
definitely worthwhile in terms of being
more precise about it so basically once
you've got the individual data you go
through the same trip generation
function but it's based on individual
data points rather in the zones so
that's a way that is estimated the kind
of state-of-the-art in travel cost is
what's called the random utility travel
cost and I'll see a little bit more
about random utility theory when they
talk about choice experiments but what
basic means is that you have a choice
about which site you go to so if you're
thinking about forests may be around
Yale has five different forests within
an hour's drive so you are someone who's
going to go walking in the forest
you choose which forest you'd prefer
so your choice will depend on the
attributes of that forest so if you're
going mountain biking it might be
different forest with my invite trails
where others don't have if you can
walking it might be once which I've got
more nature there to look at or and the
forest will be different distances to
you so what the random utility model
does is look at the suite of
alternatives and substitute sites looks
at the attributes all those sites and
tries and works out why do you travel to
that particular site what's what's the
benefits what's the environmental
quality or that site to make you choose
to go there so what you're analyzing is
people's choice of forest to try and
then a certain value of that forest and
different components of it so once
you've got that data then you can work
out the value of that site so you can
meet things like choices of whether you
go fishing or whether you go walking in
the forest so your random utility allows
you to identify reasons why people go to
that site and also pool white people
don't go to that site and you can get
much more information about why people
go to that site and if there's the only
one of a travel cost method you can
really get idea of the value of
different site quality the value of
conifers compared to broadleafs and so
forth and therefore if you are thinking
about managing a forest to say plant
more broadleafs through this technique
you can see what the benefits are that
different management regime might be
okay so that's going to broad over a few
of the different methods what I want to
do now just explore some of the
theoretical assumptions and some of the
issues there are still lots of issues
you have to think about and there's no
right or wrong way to addressing it but
the main thing is you have to seriously
consider it
the first thing is a type of traveler so
the best kind of type of person is at a
trip so if I come from home I travel to
that site enjoy myself and go back home
and if everybody did that travel cost
method would be great
there's no real problem you know that
people are just traveling to that site
for that reason and therefore we can
assume that all the travel cost is
related to the use of that site so that
would be great but unfortunately people
are more complex you get people multi
destinations so if people are in holiday
survive come to the States then how do
you know that my main reason for coming
here is to go to a Grand Canyon or
whatever or was I just happening drive
past the dry kanban Canyon thought oh
what's a bit cool let's have a look at
that so you need to try and work out how
you do it one possible approach is
saying well if someone said holiday you
only look at the cost from their holiday
hotel to see the Grand Canyon so it
might be staying in Phoenix and I Drive
up to Crown Canyon so I only use the
cost from Phoenix or Grand Canyon rather
than the cost from a UK flying over and
so at least there you know you're going
to get conservative estimate and you're
not going to overestimate it so that's
one approach but you might want to be
more sophisticated on it so these type
of multi trip destinations violate two
basic assumptions and and the base
travel cost method so first one is a
travel costs people occurs a good proxy
to the monthly value of outside so if
you've got multi trip destinations we
don't know if that's quite the case and
the travel costs can be simply
calculated well they can if you're just
people on the tea trip but you need to
really think carefully about how you
think about travel costs you need to ask
how important that site is to your
overall hold the experience and so forth
and you can maybe adjust them that way
so a whole bunch of ways have been used
to try and deal with that the second big
issue is a value of time so should it be
a fixed percentage of my wage rate so it
should be 5% my wage rate or 30% my wage
rate or should it be actual cost if I
worked overtime but I don't get paid for
overtime so that doesn't work
but for working McDonald so we get paid
overtime
so there's issues about why is your
opportunity cost of time in terms of a
recreation experience and to a large
extent people have agreed it should be
maybe about 30 percent of your wage rate
is it can a reasonable assumption for
your opportunity cost time for
recreation then there's other questions
about should I include only the time
traveling to the site or should have
included time at the site so if I'm
going to crank Canyon it's going to say
I ran up and down it so it took me an
hour and a half to get up and down it
but most people six hours whoever but
they're spending six hours in the Grand
Canyon shoot I include all that time for
it or should it just be my time
traveling so I'm giving up six hours to
be here so maybe you should include it
so again there's a bit of debate on that
so that's good debate by Cesario on how
you shoot include time and the different
theories to it and again know these
really concluded but the main thing as
long as you're explicit about what your
assumptions are and you might want to
some sensitivity analysis on it as well
then there's how you specify trip
generation function so in the basic
zonal travel cost model we're
aggregating everything across everybody
living in that zone so it's very basic
in terms of that and you're not getting
any variation in terms of people's
social academic graphics or differences
in people's travel time so it chances
are there's going to be lots of error
within that approach and some have
questioned whether the zonal travel cost
method actually violates random utility
theory so it's not really sticking to
economic theory about how people choose
to consume different goods and services
there are issues about the zonal travel
cost method the individual one where we
are collecting including demographic
variables then it aligns much better to
economic theory so it's a lot better
that way and then with the zonal one we
can add an environmental attribute so we
get much more information about
the environmental quote or the value of
environment the quality of different
sites and how people relate to different
substitute so okay so to kind of sum up
about the travel cost method it's an
excellent probably the one of the best
ways of working out the use value of a
recreation site so it's a really good
technique to use the early was on the
melt model it was great and in terms of
demonstrating how you can do in first
developing it but there's lots of
assumptions there are and a lot of this
assumptions create problems but the
random utility one and individual one is
much better or so they're quite highly
recommended especially the random
utility one they're quite highly
regarded okay the second main technique
is continually asian and this is a
stated preference technique where we use
surveys we directly ask people how much
you willing to pay for this
environmental resource and my PhD was on
contingent valuation in the kind of late
80s early 90s and what was great it's a
huge debate going on about whether it's
violet and there's a big review from
NOAA about whether contingent valuation
can produce real value estimates and
there's just a better time as a I submit
my PhD and there's thorgy whether a
frequency contingent valuations rubbish
or it works fortunately for me if they
say that works with some other issues so
I passed my PhD but it's been a was a
fascinating academic debate and for lack
sake it's a really interesting case
study so what you basically use as a
whole bunch of surveys and you go out
and ask people watch your Maximillian
willingness to pay so wtp is released to
pay for an environmental good or service
and because as market failure to the
reasons we described last day then no
market exists for less so you have to
create a hypothetical market so you have
to describe a set of circumstances in
which is environmentally might be
provided and also how people would have
to pay
for this environment good and some of
the debate has been saying well you're
asking a hypothetical question so do you
get hypothetical answers and we'll come
to that later on as well the or we say
here it's willing to pay but you can
also ask how much you're willing to
accept in compensation for a gauge but
generally speaking people don't like
willies to accept so if you ask someone
how much you're willing to pay there's a
budget constraint in there so you can
only pay so much as you've got in terms
of disposable income you can allocate do
that
we're a vashu how much you would be
willing to accept if we cut down this
forest then there's no limit there's no
budget constraint so I could say yeah I
I'll only allow you to cut this forest
if you give me a million dollars there's
no budget constraint there where the
willings to pay you're only making
$50,000 a year
you can't go more and maybe ten thousand
dollars of the maximum but probably a
lot less so willing to pay is a much
preferred method in that there is that
budget constraint so basically what you
do is you work out I mean willing to pay
and you gross it up by the affected
population so how many people's affected
by this change if we're looking at use
file view it's relatively
straightforward so I'm if I'm asking you
how much you're willing to pay to
enhance the biodiversity with an eel
forest then if was a thousand people
from yield good of that forest it's
quite easy to get that affected
population we can work it out if you
start talking about non use values then
when people having an option of using it
or bequests values then you've got much
more bigger issues about what your
effective population is so our people in
New York effect it what about people in
the west coast of California
I mean Europe affected by it probably
not if I've never heard of it but you
you know it's very hard to tie down
who's the affected population when
you're talking about non-use values and
there's big issues about aggregation of
the news values again I'll talk about
the Exxon Valdez
for that okay so contingent valuations
based on a questionnaire and there's
generally three sections to the
questionnaire the first is a description
of the environmental good and how that's
going to be provided and again it's a
hypothetical description in that there's
no market for it so you have to create a
story almost thing this is how we'll be
done so if we're thinking about say
environmental improvements in your
forest we might want to say that either
a local trust fund or the local Forest
Service will go and they'll plant more
broadleaf weeds they'll make some open
spaces they'll take some ponds and so
forth so we kind of seem that there's a
potential that the Forest Service's will
do environmental Hans's means to that
forest but it's going to cost money
and the only way that we can pay for it
is if you if the population or users pay
for that so whether it's some sort of
entrance fee or it's a local taxation so
you need to think about a way in which
we can get payment for delivering those
benefits so the hypothetical description
needs to be realistic so people buy into
it so if they think okay I will have to
put my hand in my pocket and kind over
some cash to gain that benefit so talk
about that in more detail in a moment
the next thing is how you ask it will
needs to be elicitation question so
there's various ways in which you can do
whether it's increases in taxes or
donations if you ask an open-ended
question or you ask some discrete choice
questions again or I'll discuss how you
might go about that question and there's
pros and cons for different ones and
then you need to ask some background
information so shows the economic data
people's preferences to environmental
good so the reason for that is you want
to regress willing to pay against the
characteristics of respondent to trying
justify so it's what you were saying
earlier how you justify it so if your
grass willing speak and say income you'd
imagine people with higher income with
generally people willing to pay more
people who have strong environmental
preferences that probably willing to pay
more for environmental programs and
people not so it's trying to
get information to justify your your
findings so going through each of those
bits and stage why we create a
hypothetical market because there's no
real market there so that's why is
market filled here and that's why you
need public provision that's why we're
doing these surveys to try and value it
because there's no market price and that
hypothetic the market needs to be
understandable meaningful and plausible
so it has to be as realistic as possible
to respondent they have to completely
buy into it think it's going to work
believe that that environmental change
will happen so you can need a lot of
kind of pilot testing and discussing
with experts in the public to try and
see what works for this scenario and
there's no right or wrong way of doing
it and different scenarios will require
different ways and approaches of doing
it so you need to think about your local
context so one example might be in a
study I used in UK was looking at how
much people were willing to pay us
increases in taxes to improve
biodiversity on farms and the program
was going to be an a green varmint type
scheme which be funded by government but
we wanted to do that then the government
would have to if the public would have
to pay towards taxes to do that so that
and often for environmental gates
because the public funding often
environmental taxes or some sort of
Taxation is a useful tool for doing it
then we get the payment instruments so
how do we suggest that people pay so
we've got there increase in taxes which
is probably the most widely used one you
could have donations to a trust fund so
some sort of charity but the problem
with that is people tend to have a
certain amount in their head about how
much you give to charity so the problem
with donations to trust funds is you
might be uncovering how much people pays
to charity rather and how much they
actually value that environmental
resource so people have used it but
there are issues with it entrance fees
can be quite good if you can persuade
people that they should be paying in the
entrance fees so it's a suitable way of
doing it so if it's a very restricted
or a forest park then you could possibly
have a entrance fee where it's maybe
more of a wilderness area then it might
be infeasible to collect something like
that then as payments for higher Cades
high price for gates so if perhaps
looking at clean water so how much would
be willing to pay in your water bill to
reduce health risks from water or to
make it cleaner so that might be an
example of paying higher prices for
goods and your overall aim when you're
trying to choose the payment vehicle
this reduce a protest bid so a protest
bid is someone when you ask him how much
you're willing to pay or are you willing
to pay $10 first environmental good as
an increase in tax and that they said no
because I spear enough taxes I don't
want pay more taxes that is a protest
but what they're doing is saying they
don't want to pay more tax and not
saying that they don't value that good
and so what you need to do is after
asking Willie's to be questioned you ask
him well why did you see that amount and
if you get protest bids they need to
move from form of a sample they're not
really seeing anything you might get
people say I don't want to pay more tax
because I don't give a monkey's about
environmental improvements in this
forest and that's fine that's a genuine
zero bid but you want to avoid protest
bids you want to try and reduce a number
of protest bids as much as possible so
here we look at elicitation questions
there's kind of whole suite of type
questions and I'll show you some
examples in the moment the simplest
forum was maybe an open-ended do you
simply say how much are you willing to
pay for improving environmental quality
in yield forests how easy questions that
answer but just tell me how much you
think you'd pay if I could improve a
biodiversity Neil forest
it's quite hard isn't it so generally
speaking we don't really use open-ended
because one it's very difficult and
second it's not how you meet norm
purchase decisions if you click the shop
and you buy use the last day of you buy
a sandwich that's how much costs $2 and
your decision is I is that Sam which
worth $2 to me yes or no and therefore
you make a discrete choice
so this discrete indicators is tend to
be the preferred ways so you ask someone
are you willing to pay two dollars to
improve biodiversity in your forest and
you'll think about okay yeah
biodiversity is cool okay two dollars I
can afford that yes I'll do it
benefits worth it so you may be asked
some of the sub sample one sub sample
two dollars you might ask a next one ten
dollars and you'll find that some people
think okay
ten Polar's bit expensive some will say
yes some will say no another sample they
say $100 most people say hundred dollars
like can't afford that no I don't love
biodiversity but it's too expensive and
so what you get is different proportion
of people saying yes to different mines
so more people say yes to lower mines
and fewer people say yes to high amounts
and we can take that information to work
out the value so it's the street choice
there's then called the referenda so
rather than stating are you willing to
pay a certain amount you frame it within
the referenda vote so he said we say
would you vote for improving
biodiversity in your forest
if that policy was going to cost you two
dollars an increased taxation and that
referendum is the the recommended
technique and it was recommend through a
newer panel review which I'll talk about
later the problem with that is referenda
is great in the US because there's lots
of referenda where in UK we don't really
have wrap around those so if you try and
use the referenda people don't really
understand it so we tend to stick the
discrete choice rather one of the
problems with discrete choice is if I
ask you are you willing to pay 10
dollars
and you say yes then the only
information I have is you are willing to
pay up to $10 I don't know if you're
willing to pay 11 or 12 or so forth so
it's a whole information gap about how
much you pay or if you say no to $10 I
don't know if you're willing to pay $9
or $2 all I know is you're not prepared
to be $10 so you miss out a whole bunch
of information so going back to this
discrete choice if I ask you about $10
all I know is are you willing to pay $10
or not and this whole gap of information
so people started doing discrete choice
with follow up so what that means is you
say are you prepared to pay $10 if you
say yes I actually are you willing to
pay $20 if they say no then I know their
value somewhere between 10 and 20 if
they say yes to that and it's over 20
and so forth so while that's trying to
do is just narrow down what the value is
so get more detailed information about
that so it's maybe less still less
efficient and and open-ended but open
and it's just too hard so to give you
some examples how you might frame it
here's one I did for an open-ended
survey on Drake Heights which is a
raptor a bird of prey and we asked
people what's your maximum willing to
pay today - well sky trust so it's a
charitable trust in Wales for protecting
and increasing rake height so red kites
were almost extinct in UK and there's
only two breathing pairs about 50 years
ago and now where I lived you see red
kites everywhere if there's cominis
crows but that was partly due to this
but we've asked them how much we were to
pay the continued efforts of kite
conservation so that was an open-ended
question but what I did there was I
asked half the sample the c-d-c be
hypothetical question and I asked the
other people to actually put their hands
in their pockets and make a donation so
I was looking at comparing at real
donations with these hypothetical cvd
Nations and unfortunately the result
sure that the hypothetical Seavey people
were willing to pay more or four times
more than they actually gave
which can explains the question but and
a number of other service accounts
similar things but there are surveys to
try and work out how you can reduce that
so there are other surveys that have
managed to work out ways in which you
can get Eco values so there are issues
with that element this example of
payment card so it's a study on
biodiversity in UK I did so what you do
is you say the respondent here's a range
of values pick which value you feel is
most appealing to pay from that list so
it kind of helps them choose a value
some of the issues with that is you get
what's range by it so I think okay
they're asking me somewhere between 75
pounds and 700 pounds maybe my value
should be somewhere in the middle and
there's a danger that people choose
somewhere in the middle so to test for
that you might have some people some
sample start from 75 to 750 you might
have another one from 600 to 2,000 and
you might have another one from 10
parents to 90 parents there are 90
pounds and what you should find is the
mean value should be consistent across
the three ranges so you should be able
to demonstrate that if you've got
different ranges you still have the same
mean value so if you aren't in payment
cards you need to do that just the
validator people aren't choosing that
figure in the middle so it can be used
but there are issues with it then it's
just a study I did tonight I have this
particle and Iowa State uni quite a few
years ago and we're looking at water
quality in Clear Lake we use the
referenda so we said how much or would
you vote yes the referenda to improve
water quality as described and we had
described beforehand and if its program
cost you hundred dollars yes or no and
what you get is some people get $100
some we get $50 and we get $10 so you
maybe have about eight total prices and
different sub samples we get different
amount and you're looking at what
proportion or people say yes do the
different amounts
okay how we then analyzed those
responses so if you had an open-ended
survey then you could just work out the
mean will lease the place you could just
get an average mean however you tend to
have a big spike it's zero so you'll
have a whole bunch of people saying not
no I'm not willing to pay anything so
ideally you should use a two-bit model
so it's just a regression model that
accounts for a big spike in your data so
open-ended models is how you do it so
it's just a normal aggression that
accounts for a spike of lots of people
seeing no or zero moment we talked about
random utility travel cost methods and
very much the contingent valuation and
choice experiments I'll talk about later
is based on random utility and what it
means as utility use and individual
gains from consumption of a good is made
up of some observable deterministic
component and a random component so
basically if I ask you how much benefit
you came from going to yield forest then
I can get some information I can ask you
separate questions so do you like
walking and connect side what's your
income and so forth there's a whole
bunch of things I can ask you that might
determine whether you go to the yield
forest or not
so there's deterministic and I is a
research I can work out from you then
that's a whole bunch of other things so
it might be that your granny took you
there when you're a little kid you've
got all these fond memories but me as a
researcher is not going to work at night
there's a whole bunch of random issues
that I can't work out so if we look at
the two theorem and this state component
so you've got the intersect then you've
got the bid amount so if I'm asking you
are you willing to pay to go to this
forest then part for your response will
depend on how much I'm asking you so if
I'm asking you to pay more the chances
are you're less likely to go there so we
regress the yes/no response with the bid
amount so are you going to say yes or no
and said here is social
characteristic so your income whether
you're a member of WWF or any other
environmental organization so anything
else that might affect your consumption
of environmental good and we run the
regression and to work out the
willingness to pay we take the intersect
over the bid amount so what we're
trading off is all the other things that
might affect you against a bid amount
and that somehow by magic gives you the
willing to pay amount so you basically
do this regression and you use the
coefficient of the bid amount to work
out they're willing to pay okay there
are certain things so I might ask you
how much you're willing to pay and
there's a whole bunch of things that
need to try and remind you before you
answer that question and that's gonna
stand or say of all things that you need
to consider before you ask it so so just
before I'm about to ask you when least
pay I can remind you say well think
about the amount of benefits you gain
from the environmental program
improvement so you need to focus on what
benefits you personally would gain from
this environmental program in order to
make a payments or in order to pay your
ten dollars you need to think about what
you can do not spend your money on so
think about the implications you're
spending ten dollars on this
compared to all the other things you
might spend $10 on so think about
substitute things you might spending on
if a total amount you're willing to pay
is not enough and the policy might not
be introduced so that's to try and stop
free rider so just to make sure if you
do want this to happen you have to say
yes so you're not having any strategic
bias this is a type of cheap talk
statement so saying that people have
tended the state and the mind which is
more than T to actually be willing to
pay so you have to really think that
you're going to or at the end of this
evening or the questionnaire I'm going
to ask you for that amount so you have
to really think that you're handing it
over so you try and remind respondent of
all those different issues
might also think about substitute sites
and so forth so that's before you ask it
willing to pay crashing and then there's
a bunch of questions you need to ask us
afterwards and what you're trying to do
there is make sure that people are
choosing a bit amount for real reasons
so genuine bid or reasons might be the I
chose a policy option because I could
say that the benefits are worth the
costs so you think this is a benefit so
I came from that program and those
benefits are worth the cost to me so
that's that's great they're thinking
about what they get for the money so I
had to genuinely impose at the bid or he
might get this saying I didn't choose
EMI because the benefits were and
weren't for the core so it's too
expensive and I wouldn't really benefit
from that so it's a genuine C or a bid
and that's fine people don't value it as
that much so they don't want to pay that
much so there are genuine response then
there's a bunch of protest bid so I
chose a policy option their respective
of course so well that's basically
saying is I thought I'd get this
improvement but I didn't really think
about how much its cost so they're not
considering it cost to them so you have
to reject them remove him from your
dataset this one's a protest bed so I
chose a policy option but I didn't want
to pay more tax so what they're doing is
protesting against the tax so they don't
want to pay for it so again they're the
rejected the Nitro is randomly so again
they're not really thinking about it so
you can't use their data in terms of
biases questionnaire earlier I said what
things might bias results this what's
called incentives to misrepresent
responses so strategic bias if I really
want my diversity to happen in Neil
forest
I might state that willing to pay a much
more than I really we - so there the
people are acting strategically to try
make this happen
lighting cube buyers so if you think
about that
bidding game where the range of prices
then that range of price might influence
how much people state so that's some
sort of starting QB so my
influence people's mind soup a so again
you have to think about how you might
test for that scenario miss
specification playas this was a big
issue so these like part whole buys for
school biases so it's a big controversy
that some people had done surveys where
they try to value one level of revision
and there and a bigger level provision
and people weren't able to think about
the difference in value of those
different scopes of a policy people like
kind of min clutch and diamond Heisman
argue that contingent valuation doesn't
work because there's not sensitive to
the scope of environmental change but
research since and I've kind of said
well their studies were bad so you can
ignore them but it was a big debate in
the early 90s about those issues then
there might be issues about aggregations
or how you aggregate especially for non
use values again to answer a question
from before how to ensure your
valuations are accurate so the key thing
is you need to do lots of pilot tests to
make sure people are answering this
question error as you want them to and
you need to try different scenarios to
make sure that you're not getting
results it might be badly affected the
invalidity tests content Felicity before
you have to do there is you make sure
that the information you're presenting
your survey is true and so you need to
talk to experts experts make sure that
your information you present them is
correct know so you need to make sure
that the way you respond and perceives
that information is correct as well so
they're not thinking in other ways you
can do what scones construct validity so
you could compare your results from a
choice evaluation study with one from a
travel cost and that might allow you to
validate results by comparing to some
other study learners criterion validity
in there with your regression a willing
to pay again in social economic data of
a respondent so what you're trying to do
is
provide evidence that you can justify
willing to pay so you'd expect people
with higher incomes be willing to pay
more and so forth so you know trying
demonstrate you people are thinking
about how much you're willing to pay and
then it's it's no a guidelines which in
1989 the Exxon Valdez crashed in the
Alaska and there's big oil spill and
there was a contingent valuation study
undertaken by Richard Carson to look at
the damage cost of that oil spill but
looking at non use values so they did a
study of people in America about how
much be willing to pay to avoid future
oil spills in Alaska so most people
Midland America probably don't kill
Alaska so it's not direct use and
there's a result that there was a big
debate so Exxon to all come they said
well actually this is all rubbish you're
asking people hypothetical question
about how much you might be willing to
pay for something happens up in Alaska
this is all rubbish
and as a result of that NOAA set up a
panel expert with Kenneth arrow and
Robert Solow who are Nobel prize-winning
economists to work I can contingent
valuation estimate non-use lost existent
values for natural resource damages so
can we use his techniques to work out
the value of environmental damages so
they did a big review of contingent
valuation it's published and 1993 it's
just as about my PhD and fortunately
they said that the panel concludes that
CV studies can produce estimates
reliable enough to be a starting point
for judicial process for Damas
assessments including loss passive use
values so what we said is yes contingent
valuation can work but they also said
that basically a lot of previous studies
were pretty crap as well and so what
they then did was have a whole set of
guidelines about how or what is best
practice for undertaking contingent
valuation so it's a very important
can the day for environmental valuation
and it it didn't provide a good evidence
spacing yes these techniques do work but
you need to think carefully about how
you did so you need to use personal
interview so if you've got personal
interviews you can judge whether
respondent is really thinking about it
we reviews postal surveys or internet
then you can't really judge that the
suggester use a referendum format so
using a discrete choice format because
that's how people normally make
judgments about paying for things rather
an open-ended although in UK we can I
say well you should use discrete choice
rather than that you need good accurate
descriptions of a project you need to
remind people the budget constraints so
get people really thinking about how
much they can pay and what they do or
for that we then spend their money words
on otherwise remind them substitute so
if I'm talking about yield forest I need
to say well we're only talking about
yield forest but there might be ten
other forests you could go visit but
we're only talking about this one so
again make sure they know what the
substitutes are and how these follow up
reasons for your choice so a few slides
back about whether there are protests
bids and so forth and they're really
thinking about the benefits so there's
those guidelines and they also had
what's called the burden of proof so
when you're reporting results of a
contingent valuation study you need to
demonstrate none of these things affect
you so you need is demonstrate that you
you don't have a high non-response rate
you need is them demonstrate that most
people you ask answered this question or
questionnaire if he didn't and it
suggests there's a problem with your
questionnaire you need to do a scope
test you need to say here's one level of
environmental change and that's one sub
sample that and you need to give another
sub sample and say okay here's a bigger
change and you need to demonstrate that
people are willing to be more for a
bigger change and a less change so by
demonstrating scope effects it allows
you to demonstrate that people are
thinking about the level of environm
change your thinking about it I need to
demonstrate people understand the task
you need to demonstrate that people
really believe this environments change
will happen and you need to explain how
these follow-up questions and know and
reject protest bids and all that kind of
things so here's example of the Exxon
Valdez oil spill I'm sure you all know
about was the biggest oil disaster and
they used a referendum so they had four
bid amounts so from Dan dollars three
hundred and twenty dollars and it was a
member 5 cents of people in America
under ticket survey so 67% of people
said yes I'm willing to pay $10 were 34
which will be P 120 and V average it out
you get 31 dollars a meeting violence 31
dollars you multiply it up by the
population America and you get 2.8
building dollars so this is why Exxon
was unhappy because Richard Carson came
along and said the damage passive huge
damage from oil spills in Alaska is 2.8
billion
you should compensate that amount the
reality is Exxon settled out of court
for about 10 million or something so it
was it near that amount but and that way
having these big passive use amount or
non-use amounts that's why all this new
about panel review came in to about
Nixon was fighting against this case so
advanced use of CBM because you're
creating hypothetical scenarios there's
no real limit about what you can value
you can value both use and passive or
non use values following in their final
guidelines it's now accepted and there's
a good set guidelines the problems a lot
of people argued about a hypothetical
nature of a CBM there were issues about
how or the way you pose equation might
cause biases who's trying count for it
and maybe protest birds but generally
speaking and I suppose the other problem
I haven't got up there is generally
speaking
contingent valuation can only value the
whole policy suite so one change you
can't really value different components
of it easily and that's where choice
experiments come in okay final one is
choice modeling so is this what's called
an ID attribute based preference method
and it's almost an extension or
expansion of contingent valuation so a
lot of what I've said about contingent
valuation also relates to choice
experiment but what it is with the
choice experiment is that we can value
the attributes of the environmental
resource so okay it's the same structure
of survey to describe the environmental
good you ask are willing to pay tight
question and you ask how people social
demographics but the way you ask
questions is you ask people to think
about different policy options so you
say we've got three policy options and
you describe the policy options in terms
of the attributes of options and those
are tributes may be described from
different levels so the first
implementation of a choice experiment
for a natural resource was by Fick
adamovich in Edmonton Universe Alberta
in Edmonton and he was looking at elk
hunting so he went to elk hunters and
say okay we've got three hunting
packages you can go on there's a States
quote which is a current experience so
this was generally people were doing in
that forest and we said well we could
actually manage that forest in different
ways so we could you could see different
number of elk we could have in the
forest or in open landscapes we could
have different party sizes so the number
of people you're hunting with and
there's different sizes and again we'd
get presented with a series of each
choice tasks where these levels are
presented different amounts and what you
as a respondent might think is okay when
I go hunting I like to be in a small
group so that seems quite nice but it's
45 dollars maybe that's too expensive
for me to ameba don't like that after
all too
like this one I see lots of elk is that
good it's gonna cost me 15 rather than
ten so okay it's bigger party size but
see elk and that suited me better choose
that one so what you're doing is
comparing it different attributes
against it and I'm trading it off
against the different costs and seeing
questions your preferred option I think
I showed this end of last day to some of
you this is one idea for UK first
Commission on cycling in forests and so
here there's different attributes of the
forests of different types of trails of
whether it's single track trails or
downhill cycling or whether it's
multi-purpose trails whether it's
obstacles so weathers ramps and jumps
and berms and stuff on the trails
whether spike wash facilities where
there's showers and changing rooms at
the forest some more kind of general
visitor facilities or whether toilets
and barbeque sites and so forth in terms
of information so whether there's
information about the trails on the
internet or not and the surroundings of
whether the forest is managed to look
nice or whether it's just a conifer
plantation and in terms of the costs
they use a travel distance or saying
these forests at different distances and
so what they respond them was asking
well we do travel to any of these
forests or we to stay at home so they
need to think about the idea beauty of
the forest how far it is and with the
actually go so that was what you prefer
forests and the other novel thing that
I've done although I haven't published
it yet will say well think about your
next five trips what proportion of these
trips would you go to different forests
and what's neat about that I haven't
really seen it done before is if I'm
clean biking the forest
I might go to a low-key forest which is
local so I might go four times to my
local forest then maybe once a month so
it might travel a much further distance
to get one with all these downhill
courses and so forth so probably more
better reflects away people make
decisions about things they do in their
regular basis
and you do get can they're defined
results from that compared to just which
is your preferred one so still to write
it up I think that was quite a neat way
of doing it